Bitte schön.
Ja, schönen guten Tag.
Ich heiße Mohammed. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent als Tätisch und wurde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Zuerst stelle ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen über Ihre persönliche Daten und dann kommen wir zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist es in Ordnung?
Ja.
Ja, danke schön. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Siegmund Freud.
Sieg?
Siegmund Freud.
Konnten Sie bitte die Namen bestabilen?
Den Namen und den Nachnamen?
Beide bitte. Beide bitte.
Mein Name ist Siegmund. Der Vorname ist Siegfried Ida Gustav Marta Ulrich Nordfuhl Dora.
Der Name Freud ist Friedrich Richard Emil Ulrich Dora.
Ulrich? Friedrich Dora?
Ja.
Freud.
Herr Freud, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
55?
45.
40, okay. Ja, Entschuldigung, ich habe ein Problem mit Verwildung.
Ich manchmal wiederhole die Fragen.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 17.07.1977 geboren.
17.07.1977?
Ja.
Ja, sehr interessante Daten.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Wie groß bin ich? Ich bin 1,78 m groß.
78.
Okay, und wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
Ich wiege 81 kg.
81?
Ja.
Okay, so, was fuhren Sie zu uns, Herr Freud?
Und zwar seit drei Wochen habe ich starke Rückenschmerzen.
Rückenschmerzen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Hier im unteren Länden, im Säulenbereich.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, vor drei Wochen habe ich beim Umzug geholfen, bei meinem Freund.
Und nach dem Umzug ein Tag später bin ich morgens aufgestanden und habe Schmerzen gehabt.
Also, die sind über die Nacht gekommen.
Ein Moment, bitte.
Ich schliefe das Fenster, vielleicht besser schauen.
Könnten Sie bitte noch einmal wiederholen, was ist passiert?
Seit vor drei Wochen.
Vor drei Wochen ist mein Freund umgezogen und ich habe ihm geholfen beim Umziehen.
Die Wohnung umgezogen.
Ja.
Und beim Tragen von Möbeln, nicht beim Tragen, sondern am nächsten Tag,
nachdem ich geholfen hatte, bin ich mit Schmerzen aufgewacht.
Und seitdem habe ich Schmerzen.
Ja, und die Sachen, die getrückend sind.
Die sind Gegenstände und Kapazien.
Ja, Mobil, ja, Schwächer.
Wie?
Sie haben viele Sachen, Mobil, getrückend getrackt.
Ja, genau.
Und seitdem habe ich Rückenschmerzen.
Und seit zwei Tagen haben die Schmerzen zugenommen.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Ja, hat es noch mehr zugenommen.
Zugenommen, okay.
Und nehmen Sie etwas dagegen?
Ja, ab und zu, man nehme ich eine Tablette Ibuprofen, 800 Billigarmen.
800?
Ja.
Ab und zu, nicht regelmäßig?
Nee, ab und zu.
Wenn es nicht geht, dann nehme ich dann halt eine Ibuprofen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, Herr Freude, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel
Grippeln, Daubheitsgefühl?
Ja, das.
Ich meine, in Ihren Beinen.
Im Bein, in meinem linken Bein habe ich in meinem Großzehe
ein Daubheitsgefühl.
Okay.
Steuern, die schmeißen irgendwo hin aus?
Ja, vom Rücken in meinen linken Bein hinaus, bis zu meinem Fuß.
Bis Fuß.
Gibt es noch andere Beschwerden, bis auf Daubheitsgefühl?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen, ein Daubheitsgefühl.
Also, nicht, dass ich spontan sagen könnte.
Sonst weitere Beschwerden, was beinenden Sie?
Ich meine zum Beispiel, nicht gut laufen, keine Koordination
oder Schwäche in der Beine, denke ich,
Muskelschwäche.
Muskelschwäche?
Nee, Muskelschwäche habe ich nicht.
Aber wenn ich lange sitze oder lange liege,
habe ich Schmerzen sozusagen.
Ich kann nicht lange sitzen oder lange stehen.
Ich muss mich immer bewegen.
Wenn Sie sitzen oder liegen, die Schmerzen sich verstärken.
Ja, die verstärken sich.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf der Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leichter Schmerz und sehr starker Schmerz entspricht?
Ich würde sagen sieben.
Sieben bei Bewerbung und in Ruhe?
In Ruhe habe ich 3.
Im Liegen, aber nur wenn ich ganz gerade liege.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich anwinkele, dann geht es wieder.
Also, wenn ich ganz gerade auf dem Bett liegen würde,
dann habe ich Probleme.
Sie haben gerade liegen?
Ja, ich habe Probleme.
Aber wenn ich meine Beine anwinkele, geht das?
Entlastet das?
Ja, ich verstehe.
Das bedeutet, wenn Sie beugen Ihre Beine,
dann vermindern sich die Schmerzen.
Ja, genau. Im Liegen vermindert sich die Schmerzen.
Aber komischerweise im Sitzen nicht.
Im Sitzen, ich weiß nicht, ich sitze, ich falte.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden irgendwann?
Noch mal bitte, habe.
Ich meine vorherige ähnliche Beschwerden.
Also, ob ich früher ähnliche Beschwerden hatte?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe das so stark nie. Das ist hier zum ersten Mal.
Man hat ab und zu mal Rippen Schmerzen,
aber ich hatte nie, dass es in meinen Beinen ausgerannt.
Das ist zum ersten Mal.
Ok.
Können Sie Ihre Rücken beugen?
Nach vorne?
Nach vorne, mich beugen?
Ja, es geht.
Ja, und wenn Sie die Rücken beugen,
sind die Schmerzen vermindernd oder verstärkt?
Also, wenn ich ganz nach vorne gehen würde,
geht nicht, das tut halt weh.
Das verstärkt sich.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Ok.
Ok, Herr Freud.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob Ihre Beine geschwollen,
gerottet, obermärm?
Nee, ja, die sehen beide gleich aus.
Sie sind nicht geschwollen,
Sie sind nicht überwärmt, haben beide gleiche Temperatur.
Also, es ist nichts Auffälliges.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ok.
Haben Sie Unfall in dieser Zeit?
Unfall, nee.
Welche Zeit beenden Sie? Welche Zeit?
Ja, seitdem die Schmerzen...
3 Wochen, in dieser Dusche 3 Wochen.
Also, nee.
Und auch diese 3 Wochen?
Nee, Unfall hat sich nicht gehabt.
Vorher nicht und auch jetzt nicht, die letzte Zeit nicht.
Ok, sehr gut.
Ok.
Konntet ihr bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie die Stächen, Dumpf, Ziehen?
Ich würde sagen, Ziehen der Schmerz.
Es zieht in meinen Beinen rein.
Noch einmal bitte, ich habe nicht...
Ziehen der Schmerz.
In der Schmerz?
Es zieht in meinen Bein rein,
in meinem linken Bein.
Ziehen?
Ziehende Schmerz.
Es zieht in meinem linken Bein hinein.
Und das bedeutet Ziehende?
Ja, ja.
Ich habe einen Satz gebildet.
Es zieht...
Ja, das ist neu von mir.
Es zieht in meinem linken Bein hinein.
Ok, ja, das ist...
neue Sache habe ich gelernt. Okay, danke schön. Ja, okay, Herr Freud, leiden Sie an chronischen
Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthaudruck und so weiter? Ich habe seit einem Jahr
eine Tablette wegen Herz-Rhythmestörung. Herz-Rhythmus? Herz-Rhythmestörung, ja. Okay, und noch andere
Vorkrankungen haben Sie? Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Okay, und was nehmen Sie dagegen? Bisoprolol,
nehme ich da ein. Bisoprolol. Welche Dosierung? 5 Milligramm, morgens.
Ah, morgens. Nehmen Sie noch andere Dekamente ein? Nein, ich halte es ab und zu,
wenn ich Schmerzen habe, nehme ich mal eben Profil ein. 800 Milligramm, Sie haben gesagt,
richtig? 800 Milligramm, ja. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert? Ja. Welche? Mein Blind am
wurde entfernt, wo ich 17 Jahre alt war. 17? Ja, ich war 17 Jahre alt, als mein Blind entfernt wurde.
Ja, und war die Operation umfassend los? Ja, die Operation lief alles gut, aber man hat
mir damals ein Antibiotik gegeben, das ich nicht, wo ich allergisch reagiert hatte. Also die
Operation war gut, aber postoperativ hatte ich allergische Reaktion. Welche Antibiotik,
wissen Sie? Ja, das ist Penicillin. Wie äußert sich diese Allergien? Mit Atemnot. Ich konnte
schlechter Atmen. Okay. Haben Sie noch andere Allergien? Allergie, weitere Allergien ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay. Und andere Operationen haben Sie oder? Nein, nicht, dass ich mich erinnern kann. Nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Unverdrücklichkeit? Ja, gegenwärts Unverdrücklichkeit. Wie äußert sich
diese Unverdrücklichkeit? Da kriege ich immer Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen. Okay. Sind Sie gegen
Kinderplankeiten geimpft? Ja, soweit ich weiß bin, habe ich alle Impfung. Ja, sehr gut. Und sind Sie
auch gegen Corona geimpft? Ja, fünfmal schon. fünfmal, sehr gut. Super. Okay. Das räumt mich.
Drei werden Sie erinnern, dass ich sport? Regelmäßig sport, will ich nicht sagen,
als einzig, was ich mache, ist, ich fahre gerne Fahrrad, wenn ich Feierabend habe oder...
Ja, Herr Freude, rauchen Sie? Nein. Sehr gut. Und trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja, gelegentlich trinke
ich mal ein Glas Wein zum Abendessen. Täglich? Nicht täglich, gelegentlich. Ah, gelegentlich.
Ein Glas Wein. Ja, abends zum Abendessen. Was meinen Sie gelegentlich? Zum Beispiel, wie viel
mal pro Woche? Weiß ich nicht, manchmal ist es, ich würde sagen, eins oder zweimal in der Woche.
Okay. Ab und zu. Manchmal zwei Wochen nicht und dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, aber man kann
es vielleicht durchschnittlich eins bis zwei Glas pro Woche. Okay, das ist nicht regelmäßig.
Ja, für mich ist es nicht regelmäßig. Okay, sehr gut. Okay, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht
bursundlich, haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen? Mit Drogen. Ja. Angerbar Sachen. Nein, ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Ja, sehr gut. Okay. Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, Herr Freude?
Was meinen Sie mit chronischen Erkrankungen? Ja, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Schildedrose,
Störungen, Bluthochwert. Ja, was ich weiß, ist mein Vater, der leitet an Bluthochdruckerkrankung.
Und mein Mutter hat eine Zuckerkrankung, wo sie Tabletten nimmt. Welche Zuckerspannung wissen Sie?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen. Aber mit Tabletten wurde behandelt, ja?
Wird behandelt, genau. Okay, sehr gut. Haben Sie Geschwister? Geschwister, ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Ja, Bruder, ja. Ist er gesund? Ja, er ist gesund. Okay, was sind Sie von Beruf herfreut?
Ich bin Busfahrer. Okay, sind Sie verheiratet? Ich bin verheiratet, ja. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, haben zusammen ein Kind, ja. Ist er gesund? Gott sei Dank, ja, so weit ich weiß, sehr gesund.
Ja, Gott sei Dank, das freue ich mich. Okay, und leben Sie alle zusammen? Ja, wir leben alle zusammen.
In einem Haus oder in einem Wohnen? In einer Wohnung.
Haben Sie Stoß im Alltag oder bei der Arbeit oder in der Familie?
Nee, in der Familie nicht, bei der Arbeit ab und zu mal schon. Wenn man den Bus fährt, gibt es manchmal Stress,
aber ich nehme es nicht so ernst, dass es normaler Stress hat.
Nicht besonders Stress, normaler Stress.
Wie wenn man Auto fährt oder einen Gast will unbedingt Ausleitung vom Bus und die Haltestelle ist nicht da
und dann schreien die da rum. Ich mache meine Arbeit und dann geht es weiter. Leben geht weiter.
Ja, ich verstehe. Das ist normal bei Gutfahrern. Ja, ich habe den Röschner.
Okay, Herr Freund, ich habe die wichtigste Frage gestellt.
Mussten Sie etwas hinzufugeln oder gibt es noch andere Informationen, möchte ich mir sagen?
Ich will einfach nur wissen, was ich habe. Wie geht es denn weiter? Was passiert mit mir jetzt?
Was haben Sie jetzt?
Ja, Herr Freund, es ist früher zu sagen, was Sie genau haben, aber ich vermute, Sie haben so genannt
beim Scheibenvorfall oder Linderwirbelsäule-Syndrom. Aber diese Diagnose zu bestätigen, brauchen wir noch
vorbeischende Untersuchungen, ein bisschen Blutabnahme und operative Untersuchungen.
Und dann können wir darüber reden und sagen, was Sie genau haben.
Okay.
Ja, bitte legen Sie sich auf die Liege vor der Korbischentersuchung.
Okay, danke.
Ja, bitte. Haben Sie eine Frage oder eine Frage, oder habe ich Sie zu tun?
Meine Rolle, Mohammed.
Du, wie ist es?
Hab ich einen Kollegen und eine Frage.
Ja, ich habe sie gesagt.
Ich bin Moderator.
Hab ich einen Kollegen und eine Frage oder eine Frage?
Du bist mehr als Moderator. Du bist das Herz dieser Gruppe.
Wir haben am Anfang der Anämnese eine Wörterbeisung. Was bedeutet das?
Danach linden wir so eine Schmerz-Sagen.
Linden.
Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht habe ich nur gesagt, ich nehme Ibuprofen ein.
Ach so, linden.
Du beginnst in einem Wörterbeisung.
Wörterbeisung.
Krümmen vielleicht.
Was bedeutet kümmen?
Krum werden, krumm.
Ich kann zum Beispiel eine Stange krumm wiegen.
Auf Türkisch würde man sagen, bükmäk galiba.
Wenn ich mich krüme im Bett, dann würde ich mich kümmen.
Wenn ich im Bett gerade liege, dann kann ich nicht.
Ich muss mich immer kümmen.
Meine Beine anwinkeln.
Anwinkeln.
Ich winkele meine Beine an oder ich habe meine Beine angewinkelt.
Oder wenn ich meine Beine anwinkele, habe ich weniger Schmerzen.
Oder wenn ich mich krüme.
Konntest du bitte schreiben diese Verben?
Wie?
Jetzt hat jemand geschrieben.
Ich kann nicht schreiben, weil ich mit meinem Telefon...
Anwinkeln.
Ein wenig winkeln.
Guten Tag Herr Uwe Aert.
Guten Tag Herr Uwe.
Sein Name ist Simon Freud.
Er ist 1,78 m groß und wiegt 81 kg.
Jawohl.
Herr Freud hat sich bei uns seit 3 Wochen unter Lombarsch-Schmerzen vorgestellt.
Außer dem klagt der Patient, dass diese Schmerzen in den letzten 2 Tagen sich verstärkt hatte.
Haben.
Die Schmerzen sind jähende.
Bei Bewegung, bei Krummen und entwickeln sich, verstärken sich.
Zusätzlich klagte er...
Verstecken sich die Schmerzen?
Die Bewerbung bei Anwinkeln des Beines.
Nicht anwinkeln.
Ich glaube, das war nach Vorbeugung des Beinebettes.
Was ist das für ein Anwinkel?
Er klagte, dass die Schmerzen sich bei Bewegung, bei Vorbeugung, bei Sitzung und lange Zeit liegen.
Wie bei Rücken nach vorne verstärken.
Wie nennt man diese Bewegung?
Auf Lateinisch.
Flexion.
Flexion und Extension.
Das ist eine Reclination und eine Inklination.
Inklination?
Ja, Inklination.
Nach hinten, Reclination.
Der wir bezeichnen.
Die Schmerzintensität entspricht 3 von 10 in Ruhe.
Und die 7 von 10 bei Beleistung auf der Schmerzskala.
Das 2. Klagte der Patientin, Oberhalsgefühl, Parsthesin.
Oberhalsdhesin in Linkenbein.
Linken kompletters Bein?
Ich habe ihn nicht gefragt.
Er sagt, glaube ich, an der Großzähne.
Nur auf der Großzähne, nicht ganz.
So wie klagte er Oberhalsdhesin in Linkenbein?
Was für ein Schmerzcharakter hat er beschrieben?
Das haben Sie gefragt?
Ich habe gesagt, die Schmerzen sind Ziehen.
Daran hat er ab und zu über Profen 800 Milligramm über Profen angenommen.
Er klagte als Ausloser eine Trägung.
Er hat einen Mobilentragung.
Er hat einen Hebens.
Er hat, ich würde das wie er gesagt hat,
dass er bei einem Umzug geholfen habe,
bei einem Umzug geholfen, wo er sehr viele Sachen,
Möbelstücke, Kartons getragen habe.
Wie kann man das sagen, aber immer kurz im Satz?
Ja, tragen, was denn?
Ich kann auch eine Abwechstasche tragen.
Ich kann auch ein Brot tragen.
Aber tragen würde ich nicht sagen.
Natürlich hat er getragen, aber Möbelstücke beim Umziehen.
Ja, oder wegen Tragen?
Tragen, kein.
Nachdem er viele Sachen, schwere Sachen getragen habe,
vielleicht hätte er am Vollgetag die Schmerzen gehabt.
Okay, der Patient klagte als Ausloser,
diesen Beschwerden.
Nach einem Tag, nach sehr vielen schweren Sachen getragen.
Ja, trage habe glaube ich.
Also, ich kann jetzt nicht konzentrieren.
Irgendwo ist aber ein Fehler drin.
Aber noch mal viel.
Okay, diese Schmerzen sind nach schweren Sachen getragen.
Ja, aufgetreten.
Nichts sind aufgetreten, sei nach schweren Sachen getragen, vielleicht.
Ja, das ist einfacher.
Die Schmerzen sind nach schweren Sachen getragen.
Ja, aufgetreten.
Okay.
Die Fragen nach eilischen Beschwerden, vorherigen, eilischen Beschwerden,
wurden für nein, so wie Unfall auch für nein.
Die vegetative Anämnense ergab.
Das ist eine Rhythmusstörung.
Dagegen nimmt er bei uns ein Prolohl 5 Milligramm einmal täglich.
Er nimmt über Profen bei Bedarf 8 Milligramm ein.
800 Milligramm.
Der Patient hat Penicillin-Allergie, die sich mit Duspnoe äußert.
Er hat Diplofenac-Unverzweglichkeit, die mit Diaro und Bauchschmerzen äußert.
Der Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Er ist 5 Mal gegen COVID-19 gegeben.
Er treibt manchmal Sport und zwar einen Feindtagen mit Fahrradfahren.
Der Patient raucht nicht.
Alkoholkonsum, ein Glas Wein gelegentlich.
Ein, zwei Glas Wein pro Woche.
Manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Die Frage nach Drogenkonsum wurde verleint.
Die Familie hat eine Nase ergab.
Der Vater hat Arterellehypertunie.
Die Mutter leidet an.
Der wird mit Tabletten behandelt.
Er hat einen gesunden Bruder.
Herr Freud ist Busfahrer, verheiratet und hat einen gesunden Sohn.
Sie leben alle zusammen in einer Wohnung.
Er hat ein bisschen Stress, aber nicht besonders bei der Arbeit.
Das war meine Seite.
Aufgrund einer nöstischen Angehung, gehe ich am ersten von Diskursprolabs in Lumba-Bereich.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht Tumorhen,
Wirbelkanal Stenoze, Artrose und Sponduloristose.
Für weitere Erklärungen wurde ich folgende Maßnahmen durchführen.
Als erstes Schrieb wurde ich korboralisch untersuchen.
Blutabnahme und einige operative Verfahren durchführen.
Beide sind korboralisch untersuchen.
Ich möchte eine Blutdurchblutung, eine Motorik und eine Zerlebität untersuchen.
Ich möchte eine Arterie durch Selis Bedis,
Arterie für Pupilitären, Arterie für Moralis und Arterie für Pupilitären.
Auch bei Sensibilität ist die Vergleichung zwischen Beidebeinen.
Auch bei Korbischentersuchung, bei Inspektion.
Vergleichung ist die Hautfarbe, Hautwärme und Wärme.
Die Nervenreflexion.
Wie nennt man das sonst?
Muskeleigenreflexion.
Blutabnahme wurde als kleines Blutbild,
mit einer Erleichterung von 1,5 Meter,
für den Entschuldungprozess auszuschließen.
Die erste operative Untersuchung,
musste ich rund gehen,
um 2 Ebenen durchzuführen,
oder für Anlass.
Was würden Sie in einem Röntgenbild,
z.B. zwischen einem Röntgenaufnahme und einem MRT,
die Hauptunterschiede?
Ja, und um den Aufnahme gibt es weniger Informationen,
aber es gibt sehr gute Informationen über die Knochen.
Auch Spondylostasis,
auch eine sehr gute Methode für Beurteilung,
auch für Osteoporose,
Spontanefrakturen
und Arthroseveröhnungen.
Aber mit MRT können wir die Weischegewwebe beurteilen,
Diskus Prolas, Diskus Protrosion,
auch die Wirbelkanal Spinoza
und über die Nervendrucken.
Was würden Sie sonst sagen,
Anstatt Druck?
Ja, über die Nerven
und über die Methodeauplung.
Sie sagen Nervendrücken.
Ob ein Nerf gedrückt wird, meinen Sie?
Ja, genau.
Ob die Nerven gedrückt sind.
Komprimiert sind.
Die Beurteile, die komprimierte Nerven.
Komprimierte Nerven.
Komprision der Nerven, zum Beispiel.
Kann man beurteilen, ob eine Komprison stattfindet.
Ja, aber ich spreche, ob die Terabin oder
die Nerven gedrückt sind.
Geben wir davon aus,
dieser Mensch hat einen Bandscheimvorfall,
S1 oder S4-5, sagen wir mal.
Und auf der linken Seite, im MRT festgestellt.
Im Röntgen haben wir festgestellt,
das sieht alles altes entsprechend aus, unauffällig.
Wenn Sie diese Diagnose haben,
was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Sie haben Ihre Verdachtstiagnose erhärtet,
dass er einen Bandscheimvorfall S4-5 hat,
mit einer Wurzelkompressionssyndrom.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Als Allgemeine, meistens?
Generell, der ist jetzt da,
jetzt wissen Sie, was er hat.
Ich empfehle den Patienten,
die Rucke-Insklatur zu verstärken.
Generell, das ist eine spezielle.
Generell, was empfiehlt man?
Einfach ganz einfach, entweder operative Maßnahmen
oder konservative Maßnahmen.
Zum Beispiel konservative Maßnahmen.
Dann würde ich auch sagen,
nicht direkt einzelne Therapien,
sondern ich würde erst mal eine Überschrift geben.
Ich würde eine konservative Maßnahme empfehlen.
Zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel,
der Rucke-Insklatur.
Genau.
Medikamentose, Physiotherapeut,
auch diese Rucke-Insklatur
zu verstärken.
Auch Thermotherapie.
Ja, und wenn der Patient
die Obagewicht reduziert,
und schwere Sachen nicht zu tragen.
Zu heben oder zu tragen, ja.
Ja, und mit sehr gesunde Bewegung
beobachten.
Wenn man ein Rezept ausstellen möchte,
damit der Patient von einem Physiotherapeutin lernt,
damit er nicht schwere Sachen trägt,
oder wenn er etwas trägt,
dass er lernt, richtig zu tragen.
Wie nennt man diese Anwendung?
Rückenschule.
Rückenschule heißt erlernen,
wie ich mit meinem Rücken
in meinem Alltag etwas bewältige.
Ja, okay.
Und als Bewegung oder Sporttreiben
kommt die Schwimmung,
oder Schwimmen, im ersten Brief,
wenn es möglich ist.
Ja, oder im Wasser sich zu bewegen.
Man muss nicht schwimmen.
Man muss sich im Wasser nicht nur im Gymnastik machen,
im Wasser sich zu bewegen.
Nicht nur im Wasser, sozusagen.
Schwimmen ist ja wieder monoton,
immer selber schwimmen.
Aber im Wasser zu bewegen,
kann man auch viele Muskelatoren trainieren.
Versuchen im Wasser zu laufen,
zu bestimmte Übungen zu machen,
gegen den Widerstand sich zu bewegen.
Das war aber sehr detailliert.
Man muss nicht so viele genaue Therapien
und Untersuchungsmethoden machen.
Wo kommen Sie her?
Welche Lande sind in Deutschland?
Berlin.
Wird da so etwas gefragt?
Therapien?
Ja, Sie fragen ja.
Aber das ist ja nach der Brüche.
Manchmal würde generell
ein Ergänzchen,
dass man sagt,
ich würde Medikamentisytherapie einleiten,
Physiotherapien.
Man kann zusätzlich Akkupunktur machen.
Wenn die konservative Massnahme nicht helfen,
kann man an einer Operation diskutieren.
Also auch,
offen lassen.
Man kann immer diskutieren.
Man macht konservativ oder operativ.
Ich würde den Operation vorgehen.
Ich empfehle, weil keine Lehmung da ist.
Das wäre der Grund, weil keine Parise da ist.
Vielleicht kann man sagen,
keine Verbesserung
mit der Medikamentose
und der Physiotherapie Behandlung.
Dann diskutieren die operative Behandlung.
Oder bei folgende Symptome,
zum Beispiel Muskulatrophie,
Parise, Parise, Parise,
und sehr starke Schmerzen,
die mit Anälgetik nicht vermitteln.
Sag einfach generell, nicht mehr.
Das ist eine sehr große Frage.
Generell, nicht mit konservative Massnahmen.
Das heißt automatisch Medikament, Physiotherapie usw.
Wenn es mit konservative Massnahmen,
mit Therapie oder Massnahmen,
zu keinem Erfolg kommt und starke Schmerzen da sind,
oder wenn eine Parise da ist,
kann man eine Operation empfehlen.
Das ist eine sehr große Frage.
Man kann eine Operation empfehlen.
Wir erstens empfehlen,
wir sagen nicht,
wir müssen eine Operation durchführen,
sondern wir können empfehlen.
Generell.
Ist fertig von Ihrer Seite?
Ja.